abone ol
bu
sizce Ben de iş yapıyorum
bu makası neden bu kadar Özgüven
istiyorum
o Çünkü babam berberde
Ben de babamın liraydı
ve 13 yaşında makas elime aldım ve hala
tutuyorum
bunu istiyorum Çünkü elimde şu an gibi
oldu ama güncel güncel olarak en
İslam'ın cebime koyayım
1935 yılında nedenle başlayıp Doğan'la
devam eden serüvenimiz artık bende devam
ediyor 3. kuşak olarak
ilkokuldayken çıraklık yapmaya doğum
yanına giden Ben 13 yaşında babamı yani
Ustam tıraş ederek mesleğe başladım
Hayat beni babamın teşhisiyle daha 16
yaşında küçük bir hesaba dönüştürmüştü
ve boğma niye bu kadar erken diye
sorduğumda bana gülerek şimdi söyledi
Fatih Sultan Mehmet 19 yaşında Koskoca
İmparatorluğu ölmüş sen o metrekare
dükkanımı ödeyeceksin dedi ve esasında
Gerçeği söyle sonra da Sen
benim yanımda hep berbere falına olur
gitti Kadir Alkan ol işte hikayem burada
başladı Hem Okudum Hem çalıştım koca
arası bilgisayar programcılığı
sonrasında işletme ve sonrasında Başkent
Üniversitesi Eğitim koştuğunu bitirdim
Peki neden kuaförü seçtim
Bu meslek ilgilendiğim diğer alanları
daha ağır basmaya başlamıştı
insanların ayna karşısında olan o
kendilerini özgüvenleri mutlulukları ve
değişimleri benim mesleğe daha çok gitti
üniversitedeki vücudumda elindeki tüm
birikimlerle de tüm eğitimlerini yurt
içi ve yurt dışı almaya başladım vizyonu
bir kuaför olmaya çalıştım
başlangıçta on metrekare olan salonumuzu
Bugün 20 salon bu ve 150 sürekli ekibe
çıkarttık
ilk önce mahallemde sonra Cent'in de
sonra ilçemde
ilimde bölgemde dünyada en iyi olmaya L
çıktığımız bu yolla 2015 yılında Dünya
kuaförleri Konfederasyon yarışmasında
dünya ikincisi ekibin bir üyesi olduk
sosyal medyada yeni tane sosyal medya
mecrasında aynı anda onaylanıp mavi tık
almış ilk ve tek Kuaför olduk
bu
bulduğumuz anatomik saç kesimi ile
müşterilerin en büyük problemi olan
kişiye özel saç kestirme önüne geçtik ve
bunun patentini aldık
şık meslektaşlarım bu gelişmelerden
sonra artık benden bunun eğitimini almak
istediler
esasında ustalık sırası artık bana
geçmişti ki ve oluşturduğumuz sistemle
bütün çalışanlarımızı ve eğitim
verdiğimiz ortaklarımız bir araya
getirerek savunmamızı açmaya başladık
onları hayalinden bahsettim binlerce
meslektaşım hayatından bahset zincir
Kuaför olmak bugün şükürler olsun buna
ulaşıyoruz ve İnşallah hedefimiz
cumhuriyetin 100'üncü yılında 100 sene
Kalkan savunur
[Alkış]
o zeytin listemizden bahsedeyim size
eğitim sistemimizde her çalışanımız bir
yıl eğitim alıyor eğitimi aldıktan sonra
bitirme tezi olarak benim saçımı kesiyor
Eğer kesebilir sene mezun oluyoruz makas
dizisini ve sertifikasını alıp artık
Onlarla aynı dili konuşan aynı hizmet
kalitesinde Bu sistemin bir Ferdi oluyor
işte usta-çırak ilişkisi Bu da başla Biz
de
peki farklı eğitim sistemlerinden geçmiş
biri olarak
sürekli kendime Şu soruyu sordum oğlum
usta-çırak ilişkisi usta-çırak sistemi
esasında öğrenme anlamında çok iyi bir
yol olabilir mi Sizlere buldum
cevaplardan bahsedeceğim
bu
eğitimde Ekol olmuş Finlandiya bugün
usta-çırak sistemini esasında en iyi
uygulamaya çalışan ülkeler arasında
artık bunu gözünü bulunuyorlar Çünkü
artık iş teoriden pratiğe geçip ilk
evden öğrenmeye yönelik devam ediyor
Peki ülkemiz bu durumda nerede ne yazık
ki ülkemiz teorinin aşık olmuş durumda
pratikten çok uzak aileler sadece
öğrencilere iyi bil meslek edindirme
yerine iyi bir bölüm seçmelerinde Peki
işverenden ne yapıyor
işverenlerle Sizler daha üniversiteden
mezun olduğunuz gibi sizlerden deneyim
istiyor Peki mezun olanlarda bu Deneyim
var mı Elbette yok çünkü sistemin
içerisinde bu yok Peki neden yirmi beş
yaşına kadar ortalama üniversite okuyup
bu üniversiteden mezun olduğumuzda sıfır
deneyimle mezun oluyoruz i Ya ben burada
biraz üniversitede sorgulamak istedim o
yüzden
üniversitenin için kurulmuş bunu biraz
araştırdım
esasında üniversiteler
modernistler Doktor mühendis ve asker
yetiştirmek için kurulmuş
sonrasında Her meslek bölüm olamamış
bölüm olanlar ise ne yapmış
proteze geçememiş geçemediği İçinde ne
yazık ki çağın gerisinde kalmış Peki
Deneyim ne kadar önemli sizlere bir
örnekten bahsetmek istiyorum Amerika
bildiğinizi ve dünyanın Süper
güçlerinden orada yapılan bir seçtikten
bahsetmek istiyorum Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri yapılan istatistik iş
başvurularında sadece yüzde yirmi Beşlik
bir dilimin üniversite mezunu aradığınız
gösteriyor yani yüzde yetmiş beş deneyim
ve İşini iyi yapanlar istiyorlar
bu
peki ev okuyup hem de okuduğumuz mesleği
deneyimli bilsek ve üniversiteden mezun
olduğumuzda deneyimli bir şekilde ve o
işi bilerek bütün teorisini ve pratiğini
bilerek mezun olmuş sexes iyi olmaz
mıydı işte usta-çırak derken ben bundan
bahsediyorum
Usta
tecrübesine Çırağan alttan kişidir
çırak ise çok şanslıdır şu Çünkü
yılların deneyimini çok hızlı bir
şekilde ve kolayca ustasından alır buna
bir Örnek vermek gerekirse
ben saç kesimini Sizce kaç ayda
öğrenmişimdir kaç yıl öğrenmişimdir
belki işinize tahmin edenler vardır Ben
söyleyeyim üç ayda saç kese biliyordum
Ben üç ayda saç kesme başlarına
müşterinin biri boyama sormuştu Kadir
nasıl bu kadar hızlı saç kesme öğrendi
ve babamın cevabı manidardı oğluma Kırk
yılın özetini anlattım işte usta-çırak
ilişkisi bu
[Alkış]
babam dedemden bilgileri miras aldığı
üstüne kendi bilgileriyle bana miras
bıraktı ben ise kendi bilgilerimle şimdi
çıraklarına miras bırakıyorum bugün
Düşünsenize Yüzyıllık bir deneyimi Ben
çırak tarıma kolayca ve hızlı bir
şekilde attıra biliyorum ben buna
inanılmaz değerli buluyorum
Hadi şimdi bir Çırağan gözünden bakalım
kaç liramız olsun felç liramız bugün 15
yaşında da Sizce bu çocuk bu mesleği
yapıp yapmama konusunda bu işi keyif
alıp almama konusunda ne kadar zamanda
öğrenir tecrübeli bir olarak ben cevap
vereyim bir yılda öğrenir Bu bir yılda
bu işi yapıp yapmayacağına karar ver
esasında diyelim ki çıramız burada keyif
alıyor ve beş yıl ustasının yanında bu
mesleği öğreniyor
beş yılda inanın o ustasının deneyerek
yanılarak öğrendiği o bilgileri hızlı
bir şekilde kendine aktarıp O da artık
bu mesleği düzgün bir şekilde yapacak
hale gelecektir 1 2. önerimiz de çıramız
bir yıl bu mesleği denemiş olsun ama bu
mesleği beğenmediğin için burada
yeteneği olmadığını anlasın
bir mesleğe daha şans versin Bu bir
mesleğe daha bir ne daha bir ne daha
derken beş tane meslek dönemlerin
düşünün bakın beş meslek deneyimleri ve
bu çırak Hala 20 yaşında da size
soruyorum 20 yaşında beş tane mesleği
deneyimlemiş biri mi yoksa
25 yaşında da kendi misin bırakın başka
meslekleri okudum mesleği bile denemiş
olan biri mi Bence beş yıl deneyimi olan
çırak
5-0 önde başlar Bu yarışı
peki 3. çıramız
bu şöyle olsun o da bu meslekle bir yıl
geçirirsin ama Bafa fark edemezsin bu
meslekte yeteneğinin olmadığını
işte Usta burada devreye giriyor bu
sıramızı şöyle Düşünsenize hepimiz
burada Üniversite okuyoruz bir
üniversite hocası şunu ve sadece
öğrencisi Sizsiniz
bakın Ne kadar değerli Sizin tüm artı
larımızı tüm eksikliğinizi hepsini
analiz edebiliyor size geri bildirim
yapıyor ve sizlerin Belki de gördüğü
ışıktan başka mesleği yönlendiriyor
İşte bu meslekte deneme yanılmayla yani
usta-çırak sisteminde deneme yanılmayla
istediğimiz Misi bulma şansımız çok
yüksek
Bu da Elbette ustalarda
çıraklarına bir şeyler öğreniyor
Mesela ben size iki tane ondan
bahsedeceğim birinci Hanım Ben 11
yaşında bir çıram ismi güven Çok zeki
bir çocuktu
Ben ona Sultanahmet'e gideceğim zamanlar
o metrekare salonunda beraber çalışırdık
Sultanahmet'te işim olduğu zaman güven
Ben İşimi bitirip hemen geleceğim
müşteri gelirse beni ara diyorum o gün
işim erken bitti tabi ben bunu hesaba
katmadığı döndüğümde çok değişik manzara
ile karşılaştık
dükkanda Güven yaşında başka bir çocuk
çalışıyor
içine girdim de bana Hoş geldin ağabey
dedir adam beni bile tanımıyor düşün
yani
bu Güvenler dedim Güven internet kafe
verir
sen kimsin dedin ben Güven Çıray mavidir
şok
yok yani benim 11 yaşında olan o Çırağım
yapmak istemediği işleri bugün 30 lira
kazanıyorsa 10 lirasını bu çocuğa verip
taşeron işçi çalıştırıyor
Evet ben 11 yaşında olan çırağından
bugün
herkesin her işi yapması gerektiğini
öğrendim
Peki Güven Bugün ne iş yapıyor
Güven bugün çok başarılı bir bilgisayar
mühendis
ikinci önüne gelirsem 2006 yılında
YouTube'da saç kesim videoları var
Antalya Kumluca dan
küçükberber olan Aydın Turan beni aradı
dedi ki abi ben senin hayranınım
senden eğitim almak istiyorum film
eğitim vermiyor mu benim sana zararım
olmaz sen kesmeniz dedim dedi bugün hala
uyguladığımız i bu gören Eğitim
sistemimizin mimarlarından birisi
kendisi esasında da dükkanımıza ilk
geldiğinde bana ilk sorusu şey oldu
sen neden tek çalışıyorsun
Ben dedim ki azıcık aşım ağrısız başım
eleman Uğraşılmaz boşver tek çalışalım
yanlışlık Benim üç tane personel var abi
dedim ve bana şu cam alıcı sözü söyledi
tek başına çalışan [ __ ] eleman mı
çalışan çarpar beni bir şartı bu akşam
uyuyamadım
ve sabah ilk işim bir ekip arkadaşına iş
almak oldu bugün 150 kişilik bir ekibe
sahipsek mimarlarından biri de
ayrıntılandırma teşekkür ediyorum
usta-çırak ilişkisine biraz da meslek
açısından bakalım
dediğimiz gibi ustalar çırakları
yetiştirir çıraklar Usta olur Ve yine
çırakları yetiştirir esasında buradan
jenerasyonların filtresinden geçen bilgi
döner dolaşır yine mesleği gelir ve
mesleğinin gelişmesine katkıda bulunur
bu ve bu resim Bir artısı usta-çırak
ilişkisindeki Bir artısı şudur
çıraklar ustaların sınar ustalığıyla
sınırlı kalmaz yani deneyim bilgi ve
yaratıcılığın olduğu yerde inovasyon
ortaya çıkar Peki benim inovasyon neydi
dedemden mi babamdan gelen geleneksel
berberliği alıp aldığım eğitimlerdeki
vizyon ve yaratıcılığı içine katarak
kendi deneyimlerimi harmanlayarak buldum
anatomik saçkes miydi Ve bugün fenomen
oldu
oldu peki Usta Çırak ilişkisi her alanda
sizi uygulanabilirmi
Bence uygulanabilir bugün doktorluk
hukuk ve aynı zamanda da ister istemez
başka mesleklerde olması iletişim mesela
başka mesleklerde olması bu muhakkak
burada başarı sağlayacaktır Ben burada
esasında iletişimden bir örnek vermek
istiyorum zty sağlık mühendislik ve ilk
hukuk anlamında işe yaradığını gördük
ama iletişimden de bir örnek vermek
istiyorum burada Mesela ile soğukken
belki vardır Aramızda bir gazetecinin
Bir vergidir türünün bir set çalışanı
yanında onun için deneyimli elbise
faydalı olmazmı Sizce
Bence İnanmaz faydalı olur işte bu
sistem deneme yanılmayla doğru Meslek
seçiminde sebep oluyor şu Sonuç olarak
da aramızda bu sistemi de neymiş olanlar
olabilir Onlar beni daha iyi
anlayacaktır bre eğitim sistemimiz bir
günde Elbette değişmeyecek ama Tarhanlı
küfür etmektense bir mum Neden biz
yapmıyoruz neden kendimizde birşeyleri
taşı altı Elimizi koymuyoruz naçizane
benim önerim okuduğumuz okulda o bölümün
size saçı zorunlu kılmasa da Sen neden
Sizler yaz tatilinde deneyimleme
yapmıyorsunuz Bence bunu yaparsanız
çokça faydasını göreceksiniz Biz
içimizde Elbette anne babalar da var
Sizlere Önerim Ben de Babayım sizlere
Önerim yaz tatillerini Z çocuklarında
sadece tatil attırmayın İlgi alanlarını
onları sevdikleri işlere yönlendirme
bileceğiniz mesleklerde onlara 4 şoklar
gibi deneyimlemeye yapın bir hafta bir
ay Bunu siz belirleyin ve burada çok
farklılaştığını göreceksiniz
unutmayın hiç bir meslek küçümsemeyin
hiç bir meslek küçümsenecek bir meslek
değildir ve hangi işi yaptığını Bence
Hiçbir önemi yoktur bence Kural şudur
İnsan sevdiği işi yaparsa mutlu olur
mutlu olduğu iş yaparsa yaratıcı olur
yaratıcı olursa farklı olur farklı
olursa fark bu ve diğerinin önüne geçer
işte Bence en önemli kısım budur bırakın
çocuklarınız adına artık meslek meslek
edinmeyi bırakın benim çocuğum Doktor
olacak benim çocuğum bir şey olacak
demeyin bırakın istedikleri umutlu
olacakları meslekleri kendileri
yapsınlar bakın benim işini severek
yapan birçok Çırağan var bugün onlar
Dükkan sahibi
dersin şöyle parmakla gösterdiğiniz x
meslek grupları var ya onlar ayda 100
bin lira kazanamaz Ken benim
tırnaklarımı 100 bin lira kazanıyor
düşük
[Alkış]
genç arkadaşlarım sizlere sesleniyorum
Mahalle baskısının Artık uzaklaşın
insanlar sizler için ne demiş Benim için
de demişti ne der acaba bunlardan
vazgeçip içinizden geçen hangi meslekte
tutkuyla bağlanacağınız ve en iyi
şekilde yapacağız meslek hangisi ise onu
o zaman gidin şu unutmayın döktüğümüz ve
ton toprağın altında bile kalsa güzel
olsun diye bitirmek istiyorum İyi ki
varsınız Teşekkür ederim çok sağ ol